many of us used to be enemies  but rivalries  don't need to last forever  the old valley tournament is just a few  months away the stakes are higher than  they've ever been  we know that cobra kai is going to use  every dirty trick in the book there's  only one way we're gonna be able to beat  it by kicking their ass is so hard they  [ __ ] themselves  they strike first we'll pre-strike we're  getting ahead of ourselves we're gonna  take back the valley take it back in a  measured and organized approach we bike  first  [Music]  they're not the only ones teaming up  if you would have told me a year ago  that our family safety depended on  winning a karate tournament i would have  thought you were joking here we are  living in the twilight zone  you